okay it says our stream we're going to be
doing some more time with terraforming we've
been all over the map been chasing down
rabbit holes with ansible and live birds and
kmoo a KVM and Xanadu and all the difference
for me along with the Saga you know that the
end goal for me is to get a running
multi-node kubernetes environment that I can
blow up on purpose that's running on this
machine that has eight cores and 16 MB of
ram are gigabytes and I don't know it is to
be able to do it but the thing that will
ultimately testing is how quickly can we
bring a bunch of Aeons up we tried vagrant
and failed miserably because it's so old and
out of dated into a buggy and this seems the
terraformed can do those same things locally
he's been a good five hours trying to get
live bird to work with terraform last time
we did this I'm happy to report that
somebody else was helping us today while we
were playing with ansible they were like
onions I was curious why delivery thing
wasn't working for us while we were using
Camuto to provision stuff and they ended up
saying get me when I'm getting it to work we
got liver to work so I plan on returning
back to the terraforming project for a local
development and we might have to the band it
again but right now I want to see if we can
actually use liver as a provider and see if
we got around the permission from that was
stopping this before so that's just an
overview of what's planned
I do wonder if terraform is going to be more
work than necessary and I could just put a
bunch of chemo mashed together to provision
those things but as I said before I would
rather invest learning time in doing
something that's reusable everywhere and
telephone providers are we definitely more
reusable same with ansible right
ansible-playbook Sandown hocks and all that
stuff so this is a diversion from the
ansible as a workstation thing I was doing
today and just do it was summarized to this
isn't over people who have different
interpretation of this but so far my take on
terraform is a terraform to form things and
bring them up and then I use answerable to
you know connect with them and can figure
them and that is the goal another change
today as I get into this that is that I will
be doing this using Cent OS which is
Upstream from Pandora
and downstream from you know Red Hat
Enterprise Linux it is the closest to Red
Hat Enterprise Linux you can get if you want
to read about my why I changed my feelings
on red hat I wrote a thing about that you
can read it myself a casting if you know how
to get their bottom line Red Hat has
undeniable control over Enterprise Linux at
this point so you know the same reason that
I used for tomorrow for 14 years and I am as
my desktop and you know to be good with her.
I think I'm going to stick with red hat as
the base server OS for the cluster in a few
minutes cuz I'm going to build stuff in
there one of the main that compelling
reasons for doing that was the report from
one of our community members about Cent OS
and red hat just doing live bird correctly
without the permission from the cost me five
hours
the other day is a specific problem that
they had experience with Ubuntu only and it
does not happen on red hat and it makes
sense since redhead manages and owns KVM and
then and and and give him a live Burton
ansible and pretty much everything else so
so that's where we're going to go and that
the change because my current rules that's
are for this is a whatever you want to call
it this is my I think my current my current
set files are for 12 and I may be changing
these to use a red Hat's a room in which I
have not yet downloaded I am going to try to
use the existing images that we had just for
the sake of seeing if we fix the problem
that we were having before
and I wrote about the fix by the way that's
also in maisel cast and titles and it's
called
here it is 12 Papa was fixed for limber
delivered manager that's completely
documented there if you want I'll just go
ahead and edit that real quick this is the
document and fix that chunky chunky skill
helped us set up after all of it a lot of
smart people broke their heads on this
problem chunky still was able to talk us
through how to get this song to be fixed
most because they reported they've done this
themselves many many many times before to
get around problems specifically with Ubuntu
and so the report is anyways that this
problem does not exist with red hat so but I
first want to confirm that this may or may
not have fix the problem that we were having
with her from earlier and we can go from
there
anything else
what's that conservative 10 years the XML
parser swap the order of variables long ago
but redhound kept in the same because
compatibility nice yeah I don't think
there's any debate about the quality of 12
vs Red Hat software engineering team that
redhead is far superior to the canonical and
they are focused on her price is above
everything else than canonical's openly
stated their primary focus on consumer base
distros and it just so happens if people
like them for their service as well I don't
know we've got so far as of this last year
I've experienced more problems with 12 stuff
in the Enterprise related to Enterprise
Computing and architecture cloud-native than
I have with red headband haven't played with
you right now that's just been reported to
me so I'm going to make my own conclusions
are but I'm going to try this so this says
go use the volume
I will grab the sandwich Works going to grab
the image dynamically again and that was
failing for us earlier and we're going to do
it that way by 7 or so this is all the rest
of the stuff should work if you don't know
what this is you can go back and read about
it this is using each sale
and I'm going to move the terraforms to
state
and I'm going to go for it so is it
terraform
a fly right let's try it as redefine
redefine I broke something
amen don t f + 17 alright
which way did are doing all kinds of fun
things here
it should actually pull it down from the
internet
I wonder if it's going to update the DNS
entry to interesting to see
yeah it's falling down actually no that's
just making the volume
yeah that hangs we have a problem because
that's a permissions issue
how did it nice and we saw the same
formations issue as before it does not
surprise me one bit
so we're going to try something new going to
drop me
pull up I saw images without the full
entirely actually and use the default fool
and see if that fixes it I'm not going to
spend a lot of time on this if this doesn't
work I'm going to abandon it
I'll try to do an apply again
and every time I do this it downloads the
image we have gotten manager and everything
to use the default volume locations
perfectly
so it could be that there's some
configuration that happens through terraform
that over rights with the default is
that could be what's happening we don't know
but I don't have a lot of patience for this
maybe got a different her
I mean I already exists with your idiot all
right
it looks like it worked actually I know
maybe. Rent manager
I got to kill this to Leeds yes Suites
I think we got far enough on that one they
said that that other one that you just saw
by the way it is this is a Linux Mint that
we've been running
and we should probably turn it offturn it
off but anyway
I keep forgetting to eat with a route
manager you have to keep deleting the one in
pheasant work so we'll leave that up
I try to apply again after delete out to
terraform to state god dammit
at the same one again I had to fly
it happened Sarah
I'm trying to see if this if we fix the bug
we were having before without changing any
other variables
and then we can play around with a different
image San Jose tacos
are we go same problem permission denied
same exact problem
there's got to be something in here that
lets us talk to a differently
process exited while connected to blah
found in liver images no name of her storage
a real really
could not open permission denied
and here's how we know that that's a problem
because if we go
at me if you look at the configuration for
this
where's machine details you if we do
what's up is that nice so we going here we
see
where is the volume and trying to find
the volume Erica's liver images about to see
that
I just isn't it uses the images no problem
and the other one didn't use the images as
well
so if we go into this one I see the details
write this liver images of bunch of 2010
for some reason terraform has a permission
block that does not exist
when you use a varmint varlet manager
and that's a terraform problem and I have a
feeling it's a telephone provider problem so
so that says Hangout
the verdict email in Gmail I forgot to
that says it's very rude
message Christine
I wonder why that is
that's interesting that's only chat send me
the provider is doing
it seems like it's by passing the settings
from the chemo we already fix these things
I fix them
because we didn't live in Kemah called and
they said group because liver right but this
would mean that they kiwi.com
is this these configurations
are not being used by terraform that was
said that would imply that terraform is not
using live birds that it's using something
else
that's that's what's happening yeah so
I asked a big deal it is a big deal maker
it is a big deal because that's it works
weight we were able to make it work no
problem using
the current configuration using the word
manager
but when we use terraform it still attempts
to create it is rude and he's there some
setting that's not getting conveyed that
tells it that we wanted to do
whatever you want to do it as as a specific
user
I mean we could do group equals live Birds
I'm just wondering where that setting comes
from
I don't know where that sitting comes from
where the group is live right there
Phoenix soccer group of birds
hey how are you
so we're going to church today I kind of
we're doing terraform right now so
hey we definitely need
this this is definitely the problem this is
really good information so I'm kind of
taking it in
when we use the manager it creates the disk
image with the proper permissions when we
created using terraform is bracelet with
incorrect for Missions
and
that seems to me like it's completely
ignoring chemo
and that would make sense because
it's provider libvirt and Liberty supposed
to run on top of chemo but this would seem
to imply that it's not doing that
so I need to read about the live bird
provider
then vert provider
verts group volume permissions I don't want
to kill myself on this but
and I definitely want to read this
survive name source Master Akiko basically
my d
time to test the message being mean disc
our accounts
I mean desk worker
I really want those Angel the same base
image create little life the base image
name require a name for the resource
storyful where the resource would be great
if not given default we be used
optional if specified we know that size got
that
I finally got that is why I'm named guitar I
told you my dad
turn right before they make some of the
division
Saucy yeah I don't think this provides it
actually I don't think this looks to set
that uses usage
which makes me wonder if it's
are you ready hell
I don't think it's I don't think it's I
think it's a provider I think the providers
got a problem
yeah
I don't know I'm going to guess you just
here for a minute let's try that
alright so
are using it as is Ireland verts
I don't know if it's going to even let us do
that
french fry
. Thing
all right get rid of you
delete
I don't know what's going on it doesn't seem
happy now mostly because I
chocolate program c words
measure
come on baby delete go away please
storage area surface before assignment each
other
1/6 leaves Unbound are local grocery stores
references before 7 I didn't do that
we can't afford to quit this
hey I'm just not it says there's only one
there
I know how to get rid of it
and is that time is really fucking weird
alright so
terraform and it
as a reason previous version of the verb
from the dependency locked file
the song Reserve what's 6.12
okay installing Rivard Southside for a
community providers blah
so terraform terraform
install it's wrong as a group
do you want Aaron
how do you do fellow kids
are we going to sell
ARG so it's 2:10 form
apply yeah it doesn't like it
I didn't think it did I was thinking to just
stab in the dark I don't have any hopes for
this phone to try anyway
so this is what it's doing
emulator this is because it's calling Kimo
I am thing you age of all trades reviews
here to Source service
whenever you change that I feel spice
Network addresses
volume default pool
electrifly size I think it's the same one as
the form
and download the thing again it's okay go
ahead and joke for just fighting with your
form again
I stopped her from though it's the provider
that's the problem and I I'm going back to
my original plan I think of not using the
number provider which is not production by
any means
and it keeps having these errors
which is
make the whole point of it is to be able to
pull up new stuff and if he can't do it
we're just fucked
I kind of feel like we need to use SSH
instead and go into another system and do it
I don't know how to test that though
I guess I could terraform on a client
what I was doing before so do we still have
our clan up
cast is not running
delete
and this one is so going out for that so
here's our what to do if you can fit
terraform on this
and didn't work that way
but then again then again it's a question
like how do you install terraform excetera
excetera
he said message to other things xcetera
yeah I don't even think I can SSH back to
the host I do not see
so much stuff on here with doctor
what is 7 Nike Air internet
there we go that's the the router which we
are
I meanI mean I think I could get
I think I think this actually serves is
around her let me try something
God dammit
92168 today at 1
I don't know what the password is that are
they try something
yep that works okay so
I have to do something I have to do
SSH coffee
ipid no identities found
ssh-keygen
no it's just a skeeter and Jess t e d 2 / 19
yes yes a passphrase copy of yes please
and Emmett
there we go
nice all right so that is all set up to have
passed for the phrase less stuff
hey the config language is the word
ACL next
all right so we are going to make a
connection to your so what I'm trying to do
here so this here is a pretend computer so
my goal here is to make this my computer now
into a multi CPU host
and we're going to see how that could
possibly work
so yeah so what's the strident
I mean this is all very experimental but I
kind of want to get it to work so
what the hell
alright so do to to to to to
all right so so so so yeah abms
we have it's a VM but this is going to be
the terraformed client so I'm going to try
something here I'm going to try to use
terraform as
using the SSH provider I don't know
I don't know anything about your phone but
I'll practically so I'm going to try to use
the more supported terraform provide SSH
provider and I'm going to try to bring up a
remote VM
on
on a remote system and the remote system
will be the one that I've allocated here so
yeah and we have to put that into DNS
probably but that's okay
so
so first things first we need to get
terraform installed so I have to remind
myself how to install terraform
at this one is gone
so in Sumter for me is the most modern
methods don't forget to exit back to refresh
and I have this song written
in a I believe I have this written in a in
the cave at Coronavirus
this is no that's not it that's not it
cannot write it down
210 completion the night manager
oh I remember I remember I put it in my
install
carfi redaction Oklahoma, that's yeah
it's okay it's just RC so this is how we're
going to install Turf form
now I can actually copy this over so I can
have sleepy
install terraform to vien
and it'll put over here so now it's over
here
a separate machine is on the virtual machine
but it's like having a separate machine so I
can run in Solitaire for over here
and I'm asking for my password just as we
should just password
and it'll go get everything
apparently the RICO does not have a release
file 08 with you
sudu and it starts listening small small app
update
right I don't have to get up doing it from
separate windows on purpose so that
if you can kind of get a visual of it but
it's actually kind of hard to read so let's
not so I can just SSH to the VA now I'm on
that machine and I can just run install
terraform
my super secret password
does not have a release file I'm Tate unit
server
text refused
3 Debbie and like thing to do so see you
I think we need to put the the key tools and
all that stuff over here
is there a over here
Studio apps update
bring me to Camp fighted I supposed to be
knighted
I finished half a quart in a
releaseaccording to a release
does not have a release file you know what
this this VM is too new
yeah I was afraid of that is Bahamas to new
it is not supported by a scorpion
okay well we're going to have to do another
weekend then
I mean I don't know which one she is
I hope you always always use
weights
if that's that's the problem and it's just a
new God damn it well so much for that
is it going to have a super old version of
it and when I get to work so
which means I'm pretty much just have to
stop
stop this guy and make a new one
it was me 20.04 it supposed to be ready to
support I don't understand it's not
supported
terraform is not supported on the sister on
this volume
Estrella yeah because it's doing Ellis be
released us yes right
so this gives you Luna so this is it and if
you work on this one l s b
this works so this is on her suit whatever
watch it was just crazy because I'm pretty
sure mine is newer
21 + 24 condemned sings Right Now app
install
you think so
oh wait wait wait
Subaru
have transports yeah
and it could be a missing app to phinizy
that's definitely true us right again
I got a lot farther it did in a release not
supported
hi Ronald what's that about
open source Securities Market Marketplace
so is it keeps going to see a nice very cool
thank you for posting that
obscure message Christian music adoration
details
from such a project can't be insecure late
is there for just a bite at fault when is
that happened
that's new that is a totally new thing
that's totally new Sheamus versus your point
six
how can you scan that does signature
checking release files I saw like the Glide
I like it for a lot of things yet and chrome
all of the configuration cache in Chrome is
people a lot of tackling files since we
don't have any information.
If itif it if we're kind of has on some of
these files in front of all the corned beef
with you I found enough for an operations of
you. First time I talk anymore
are we supposed to freshen your style
it was all going to raise only one he's my
setting figuration to acquire a lot of
Supervisors true
everybody's gonna love it this is what I was
talking about earlier or they just made a
fatal error or not we didn't used to be a
used to be a big warning and it can also be
allowed to be in Security in the sources
option allows for equals yes note that in
scary stories are strong
so I do to do
you're honestly I ain't ya so I think it is
I think it's I think it's actually what I
understand it's is pretty bold release
this is Linux Mint
actually the only guy check in
mint 20 according to nevermind we need to do
you named Ashley
FF right now it seemed to matter you might
just fetch the binary
we had a problem with that you can't go get
the battery yeah yeah I'll turn it into
doing what we do we actually spent like a
half an hour trying to do that except for we
try to do a go install and it failed
yeah that was kind of sad it was kind of sad
we try to go get and it just failed
but I'm I'm All About just grabbing a
release in the counter the counter today
yeah let's go gather release
it goes with the regional code did you can't
even sell anymore because they kill it makes
me angry
and it's just a binary but still
installing terraform one of the options is
go get the release I just want to get the
release thing
install Turf Farm about battery
unzip the package
redirecting downloads download a form
arm64
and this is the thing we did that doesn't
work
put on yum it can't do it
do to do to do to do to do yep yep yep yep
yep
why is it so fucked up
a Yorkiea Yorkie yeah the man you sent work
yeah that's a good one let's try that one
why you talking about I haven't left
and this works I'm going to put that as my
new installer
and I fucking I hate all these facts
management.
Call Tela terraform
ha 30 equals MC temp Dash D
CD interior door Echo
exporter phone for 3 disappear
SLS core beliefs won't rev version
it's a sin to be exported and its export at
all this isn't recorded
yeah you can actually get that information
straight out the Jake you page if you wanted
it that way I did one of my way over there
the terraform
unzip terraform that's it terraform
second look at this one
of course I do who was the type Escape every
time
and you can always be trusted with remap and
caps lock
I hate I just do all that here I guess it
did I guess it
all right
Echo
okay
Z
Uncle Ben Africa
Echo then not detected on set
Exit 1
control of Rocket I do it all the time it
works everywhere
why would I rate you can read my passlock
but you can't be guaranteed it's going to
work everywhere
I have caps lock ring remapped as well but
I've been using control arm bracket for 27
years so because it works everywhere
it doesn't require any remapping
I do it. It doesn't work is if you have an
international keyboard and you can't hit it
easily and but I've heard I've now got three
people from here who said that they bought
American keyboards because of that for the
single purpose I didn't even know I found
him here and actually told me about it here
I thought I was really interested I would
never guess that's how I said thing that
people do
so much for the other shit that's way better
thanks for the thanks for the tips there
Ronald thank you so much for that Iris Perez
sobrabas already
so she had to Sue and Salgado care form
nice
a fantastic it's a much better install our I
started down that path and I I threw it out
I don't want to use a fucking package
managers anyway screw that screw that
especially since it's all right and better
install. Terraform
Asia in Vietnam Embassy happy birthday for
some reason really
yeah you just have to remap that number that
has dcyf do to get it to do it too quickly
if we therefore delete member there early
early days you have to differ backspacing to
leave old farts are ever having to do that
you sent the map delete to do the right
thing backspace delete
how do I do is print like an ASCII character
the screen you don't yet nobody gets that
from today but
so
that receipt I got
fresh
Air flight 116
thanks indeed
ascp install install terraform to the end
now we can go over here or does it different
machine just case you're wondering
yeah it wasn't certain something was weird
I've never been able to hit this game I
don't know how people do most people hit it
by the way with the ring finger they don't
hit it with her pinky most of them. I've
seen people do it and they do it they do it
with the ring finger and that there like
always up there it's like fucking crazy I
would never do that and also pisses me off
that caps lock used to be a escape and then
the typewriter Nazis took over and they they
threw it out and it looks like there and
said nobody fucking uses caps lock nobody
uses caps lock except for Trump supporters
so so yeah let's run this
govind notset fuck
eyes are always Hotel
sudo apt install gout
why you feel like 1.3 on
it's going to be why just one way 13 bad
yeah does 9
take a stroll on the right side of the keys
to yes yeah
yep that's another reason I like it
not tell gender it's coming me until you
will see the day I will do a Gentoo thing on
here I swear
I want to know how to install a Gen 2 system
on a VM how could you do that
how can you start with a bare-bones VM that
has nothing on it
does Gintama have a bass boot installer it
does right
Gentry is a based distro it does have a base
distro so you can put it you have soon as
you can put in a VM right
oh my God that's Ronnie Mac yeah that's a
class action lawsuit part of it they got rid
of it I have the computer right before the
one that is why they did that
yeah that was so stupid that knows Apple
just proving up fucking idiotic there
they are so stupid okay install terraform
I'll make your God
install what the fuck make directory
Dash p
. Local band
how are you
alright fine alright fine and I'm not full
of Iron Man so
we mean you're not you're not happy are you
not impressed
now working all right
it's okay to be in my path though cuz I
don't have my whole thing here yeah fine I
will edit my Mash RC for now
play some SMS until you're supposed to put
all your stuff that's still in motion do not
do that I don't do that
ask for Pat equals God logo pin
make sure you include path in there anybody
ever not do that
in the temple of full baths for everything
for a while
goben
in talking about if somebody in here has
done that I guarantee you
and you know I'm talking about if you have
done that you know very much what I'm
talking about
got Gavin Gavin going to make Gavin
and there's a better way to do this by the
way there's a brown respect you can do and I
just don't remember it
if
and he shot the shouters cave and get
yourself a foot pedal for a scave
he was talking about going to say they were
going to get one
yeah they're going to get a foot pedal to
make himself a faster typer are they okay
didn't drink Zoom Camp oh my God I'm already
terrified
and doing a terraform at the end of week 14
data engineering really well
I mean let's withhold judgment until I look
at it
you should go for is it free
go back do it for free and report to print
hopefully I got to know way too much of a G4
no mix now I wish I didn't know any
can shih tzus are these folks I don't know
I've never heard what they've done
gcp Docker big picture data and SQL
terraform it sounds like they're going to
make you pay a lot of money to use the cloud
I would say go for it can't hurt extended
orchestration
what Kafka
I would say go for it looks pretty good
they're doing everything in the cloud though
that's cool thank you for telling me about
that let's I hope that's successful I don't
have any idea I don't know who they are or
what they are
but and that's data stuff right so
terraform hey it worked
it looks like I like this girl well did you
do the Boost
when do we do stuff with doctor in the booth
to go try that Nationals this is my
recommendation
this is exactly how I learned everything
deep about bash I kid you not I am not being
facetious that is exactly how I learn about
Bremer expansion about completion with Dash
C
bookmarks the man page do that the Boost gym
and it's got some doctor in there that was
the first year I ever use Docker self and I
learned a lot about doctors that's in there
there are so many gems in the man page in
that get tutorial man page here's another
one is all so glad somebody told me about
this man get to tour this thing is all you
need
I'm swear to God it is so amazing
that it is it's just it's amazing it is very
clear to read
yeah and it's right there been there for
everybody forever since it on time
I reckon is it so Sunday. Bring it
oh you read out something else nice
yeah if you don't like you don't like Man
pages in The Terminal there's lots of other
ways and features are designed to be printed
of all that's that's no point are done in
Crofton drop off and now that dropped out of
me a sentence with off
hey look terraform is over here
shall we get crazy should we get crazy I M
crazy now I am going to be crazy
crazy ish I'm at that I'm going to get crazy
you're crazy ish
I am going to do terraform on my system from
a VM
I guess and I'll do I'm going to use a
different provider I'm going to use an SSH
provider this time like ansible does
so let's try it shall we I am I am very
hopeful that this is going to work I really
am I am hopeful
I kind of want to pull this down but then I
got to do my configuration stuff so I will
not
what are the mountains locally probably
could do that with an F A something
terraform Tri-State s c p
main TF2 VM colon so babe
There She Blows main idea
I can Overlook some aspects yes I don't like
that
there's also learning the Linux command line
because I'm at that yep that's free
the Linux command line William shots
actually I'll search for it and you go and
this is free
it's free errors you even the link for it
I am music
this is the link for a free pdf so it dated
but did you find it yeah no starch have to
pay that was free and if
and it's not free as in you stole it it's
free as in it's actually free
different providers I am going to use a
different provider dye dye liver. You piece
of shit promoter hey look I know how to use
the eye because I learned via instead of
some shity new event or have been with all
our checks with plugins and I don't even
have to configure it I can just go over here
and be productive sort of
yes and I'm shiting on everybody who's ever
not done that I'm sorry I don't mean to be
that mean
sudo apt install them not them tiny which is
when it comes by default
hey look it just works and I know how to be
productive because I didn't burn shit into
my muscle memory that's not the default
I'm going to run that shit in everybody's
face every time I do it because that is why
you do it
everything that you customize in your muscle
memory that's away from the standard
reinstallation takes you that much farther
away for being productive on any system
anytime you're welcome to do it but I just
know that you're getting up productivity on
another system eventually
and people that lets why the zMAX and U of M
and all kinds of god-awful shit
okay thanks V and the suffix M into it
Idaho I've been using the is why I keep
choosing me I instead of him
Pizza Inn are you trying to just you said
you mean
I could probably do it at is that over here
it depends over here got to can't remember
my thing on my commands
s r i have to it
I carry him I spent two hours memorizing all
the new admin commands I learned it like
last year I can't right now it's worth
learning though I can't wait to do it again
in during the Boost I don't use it that much
yeah it's actually pretty good you should
learn it all they can line all the colon
stuff to do with vin is Ed essentially
preferred providers the Virgin kiss my ass
you know what and I don't even know what the
providers are
terraform ssage provider
create your own assistant lazy output from
David as his total name come on
different viruses it is a mom yes it is
Nana has no business on them on any Unix
system ever is when the biggest sins and
whoever if I knew who was responsible for
putting Nano on Vin I would put them in my
permanent hate list
why are you back on the ends after living in
the docker because I want to blow the shit
out of something and when you blow the shit
out of something and darker and blows the
shit out of your system not some pretend
system
Christian on them I meant do you know
is it also extended an coax that's what
that's what Dee is VI as usual mode of X in
fact used to be. Xrc if you're on a true VI
system the configuration files xrc not virc
keyboard Mac and install Natalie me what the
fuck
is it your manager for a letter hey hey mr.
tell me why are you there you got yours on
what what is the hands-down the best
terraform provider for traditional SSH only
access like I would do with ansible with an
agent
imagine they're already I'm seeing a ton of
Provisions oars oars
what is the most common
provider for terraform besides
okay top 20 providers
electromotive Zach furniture how does that
get you something now
hairless took of the top 20 top 20 terraform
providers
gave you back sales and marketing from Jack
Farm
your audio is breaking up is it my fault or
yours it was my fault I apologize
it could be because I'm running a VM already
Turbo movie producers that is providers for
writers are essentially plugins that allowed
to inform the interaction with systems they
are either maintained by haschak or
third-party technology providers or
terrified of community members
that would be three things usually either
represents two things bad writing we will
forgive you JD Beck
I gave you back the most popular terraform
provided by the number of installs on the
chair from registry
of course popularity is always adoption is
9/10 right
mobile what's today I got you there are 8
utility providers no random archive local
external TLS DNS and http
6 public Cloud providers and I don't give a
shit three Hash a platform providers ball
Council telephone Club
one container orchestration provider
kubernetes
want to fight animation provider Helm and
one security Out Tantrum azure I'm always
I'm lurking
I'm a mama mama mama mama mama I don't give
a shit about that stuff
that does not help me no
no provides constructs that intentionally to
nothing
yeah we're not doing configuration
management we switch gears we're firing up
the VM so we're doing
or firing of NVM on a system
on a hypervisor system
but I don't even if it's possible there's a
goal I want to be able to run terraform
against the system that has an SSH
connection and then I want to run on that
system I want to cut the crap out of it and
strip shredded up and into pieces
can that be done I don't know I don't know
if it's even a thing that can be done
no resource no I don't want that
I thought of it I might actually do it
probably would have to like deliberate right
but wait a second let's am I going to be
using the verb provider with a remote URL
what it when you met me at 20 minutes to do
I think it's going to have to do god dammit
I give it right back to where we started
shit from what grades on 610 servers
shit has a big deal at work work people are
working at work
I have a generator Hold Steady until the
inputs
God damn it I am not happy with this I
actually know what I'm feeling I know where
this is going
you know it's going to end up me being do is
give me to be firing up a bunch of yams and
putting my shirt on there by hand and
calling it a day and not using any kind of
automation that's what it's going to be
tomorrow tomorrow me to have to do that like
it's probably just give up and start that
now
great. Now I'm kind of frustrated because I
don't know what provider to use I'm not
using a fucking cloud provider for this
I can come to the father except I don't want
that overseas to Medical resources files
so fast that we've been talking to some
about you the whole time God knows I love
that I love automation I'm trying to learn
the tools and people are using out there
it was a while they're not using terraform
to provision your own on Prime stop there is
a form to provision the cloud service is
okay fine
fine I hear you saying that I hear you
saying it
surprise especially my days just to provide
an interface with your form a national
program just for interfering with the
sisters which has provided does not exist
such as what
Google Beta official public policy forum
fault how this
kill us
all I want to do is what I want to do I want
to use terraform from a local Workstation
I hope this helps
what are you doing want to use Emily
12-point terraform at a remote server a
single remote server
and we want to shut that shit up want to
chop it up
I want to carve it up into 12 into 12 silver
so here's what I have I have one machine in
the case of virtual machine but we have one
machine your laptop with her and another
machine that has a hypervisor and SSH on it
and I want this one to go to that machine
under SSH and chop it up
and the more I think about what is required
for that to do that the more I realize it
depends on the hypervisor and the more I
realized it would probably be a little burnt
provider that would be running locally that
would be invoked over an SSH Connection in
which case I'm the same I'm at Square One
all over again
so I'm I'm I'm pretty pretty raised for this
out
cuz I don't think you can use terraform
I don't know but I don't think you can use
terraform to provision
I need head here if you knows this I don't
think you could terraform to provision
on-prem stuff
I know people that do I've heard him talk
about it before but
what what is what's required to do that you
know
I know of people who like stick a bunch of
servers in the corner and they put them on
the network and they manage them through
terraform and I just don't know how to do
that so I probably need to look I probably
I'm going to I'm rubber ducky in this with
y'all cuz I need to I can need to look
broader it's like
how do I manage my on-prem servers with her
not manage how do I create
unfriend virtual machines with terraform for
doing it I just don't know how
cream private server to network in Nashua
terraform
it's not on primitive it's in fucking Azure
create virtual machines whenever you want
extract resources I think it's really hard
to do it on from my cloud gives you clean
API for interface versus versus ec2
instances
azeron from I know it's like fucking is the
first it to for Microsoft if you get
something like VMware proxmox that already
have a few guys to be consumed by terraform
that's you know what that makes sense okay
thanks for that Ronald
so so yeah
I see were saying when you're proxmox that
consumes like the whole system right
yeah
like to install an approximate endpoint it's
the proxmox is Fox News have a base image
that has to get since that gets installed
I think this is dumb telling you know
I think I think that's I think this is
happening you know how many Open Force I
have
I probably have enough power and open Fords
for like for Mac Minis that I can I can pop
up instead of having to do the whole server
thing
I could probably get a couple tomorrow in
approximate sing
actually I'm kind of on board with
approximately I didn't know I wasn't as I'm
bored about it before the way my unborn now
I'm going to switch shift gears I'm you
can't do terraform unless you have a cloud
form is for forming clouds Cloud
configurations if you don't have a fucking
Cloud you can't use it
and I don't have a cloud on friends I have
to add my cloud have to have a cloud on
trans I can use terraform for it otherwise
it's all ansible in the bash crepes
yeah I'm starting to see the stupidity of my
ways now yeah the reason I keep bashing my
head against the wall with terraform is cuz
it's in the fucking name it's designed to be
or the ground where the cloud lives above
yeah
yeah they haven't released me with reading
Maybe
triggered violent address to Christian Court
reform memory done so I figure to a museum
of the following agricultural with bash or
Powershell
bite your tongue implemented terraform Cloud
on front location
say hi this is for an on-premise or 7th
I'm starting to see something that's really
obvious affect us so fucking obvious I'm
going to write it in big letters
angry mad
condemn it God damn it God dammit
shit and see comedy
rent
you can't have terraform
unless you have a Cloud 2 forum
running late for stuff down after washing oh
that's nice
fog computing the district Rock said of his
fellow sewing machines
San Diego polka days
some miscellaneous makes able to run to the
arms act like pods
Hubert yeah I know if I can
yeah yeah I know that. Here's the problem
though I want to blow up your latest
installations so
I actually need to maybe virtualize I was
headed rental I was going that path a
hundred percent I was like I don't need no
fucking viens I don't even want to learn
answer volunteer for all I want is
kubernetes on metal give me creative and
I'll put my keyboard in there and and then I
thought how am I going to test blowing up to
Brunetti's and developing for kubernetes
by what doing a VM that's running kubernetes
within that have like four layers of
Inception
I can't think too much
it's so I think
I think I know what the answer is I think
yeah I feel like I feel like I just I can't
believe it or not I feel less frustration
right now because I know I believe strongly
that I know what went on to doing wrong
what I'm doing wrong right now is
I'm trying to use the cloud cloud
provisioning tool with no cloud and it
doesn't and it doesn't work
who did not kind of a Mac Mini SSH kind of
situation right yeah I know so
but when I went to this is
you can't use tf4 provisioning your private
Data Center
not without not without a web middlegrounds
none of us here who cheers on his big dumb
dumb realizations at lucido to I love it
like someone is coming after all the region
of a sack that's exactly what I think
self
I think I think the answer is a level of
abstraction that's going to pay off in the
long run but be a pain in the ass in the
short run
so I'm going to put forward my proposals for
going forward tonight and possibly another
time
my proposal is that we deploy
proxmox or some Cloud solution for
now on a single server and we have to get
this order in the problem with that is I was
going to deploy proxy I was going to cheat
this is this is my but I was really going to
cheat I was going to use my existing
streaming system pay I was going to use my
existing streaming system
as my server and I was going to have a
remote that's what this is I was going to
have a remote Linux Mint box and use that as
my terraformed and then I was going to
provision the unused course they're all used
but on this computer from terraform but now
I realize that in order to do that I would
have to blow away my system and put whatever
the hypervisor in the minimum the minimum
hypervisor OS is on here cuz I have a
feeling proxmox can't just be it's not like
an agent you can just install it and you
think I have a feeling proxmox requires it
to be a base install image because it has to
have really low level access to to all of
the VM stuff I have a feeling I don't know
about to do the research on that if that's
true then the solution is not going to work
for my immediate need and it's going to send
me back down the path of doing the
networking
and connecting up on the neck mean he's a
raspberry pies and everything and putting
proxmox on that at least a large percentage
of it some of some of it like my my actual
performance high-performance terminate stuff
will probably be on some of the systems will
be a different we don't have a a bare-metal
give her any situation going on and then
I'll have a number of other systems are
managed with proxmox and I kind of want to
see the different site where I can compare
performance between the two victory since I
have enough McNeese to do that I could just
say okay you know you ate Mac minis are are
in the cluster and you ate Mac minis are in
foxrock Supreme cluster and you ate or not
you're just a OS is in Hermitage independent
probably from an epic kind of situation I
have to take a break and come back that's
what we're going to do though
I am minutes
all right
what the hell is that
oh my God so stupid
so fucking stupid I can't say anything else
so I have to say
it's so fucking stupid and doesn't even see
why all right fine back back to normal
I just I can't I can't look I can't wake up
let's see here other season proxmox research
so
how do I install proxmox let me do some
research
and coloring I don't know if I want to go
down this this road right now
it's her phone so it's not going to work and
some stuff I got to work so
this this this the time this project is not
a thing
that's why I do these things to learn the
hard way God knows I do
I'm going to drop this let's check in the
stack yeah
well in this case we're actually putting
more Tech I'm going to still use tear for
him I'm just going to have to do it in
proxmox
yeah Randy proxmox asked me to change gears
here so
I'm actually going to stop this one and move
on I may even
go grab a computer out of the closet and
provision in
just of the OS on it I don't think I can do
a network boot to get all that stuff so it
will take a peek
get Annette
I mean my field Labs I think are just as
important as the other ones cuz I want to
see people to see if they try it you can't
do it
I
when
this is going to be I don't know if I want
to go all the way back to vagrant or not
uncle
you must virtualization for six months to
see in this new tech gives you anxiety yeah
this is how it has always been the one that
blew up
what are the vagrant liver plug-in with work
now that we got the permissions problem
fixed
we tried it with the telephone thing failed
but I wonder if they Grant Wood would work
now
we haven't taken away before we leave this
let's go look at it reversing it when you
were here for that right
generic YouTube
yeah we already tried that we try that we
spend a whole night on that and then it blew
up
is also openstack yet people were saying hey
where you going to use openstack vs. proxmox
I actually think openstack is probably
amor macrostax is a ton
yes yeah yeah I'm a sex one with a few other
people talking about all the different ones
let's do try bigger and see what's up though
it's okay maybe for a super stubborn. Don't
forget to install the plug-in provider
created box is too big and plug-in install
megabox ad
this Maxi might work now that we got the
other problem done when that be ironic
now Nexus and mainstream enough I would love
it though what is going to work
is it raining
and generic
oh God
and if we can get bigger to work as as old
and busted is it is it's it's the target
hits the target solution for what I'm trying
to do it is the calm that says this is it
Target use case is for software developers
to recreate application development
environments quickly using their local films
that is exactly what vegan is for it just
happens to be fucking broken refused chemo
and Katie m
so
yeah I'm going to go over to work that's it
thinks that that one exists it actually
doesn't
if any boxes severe holyshit
that that's the first time that has happened
defaults not created virtualbox 08 do we
tell it Levert
shit the hell are blood or other one I think
I might have
now what to do what the hell
what is an ad
shit it works oh my god it worked
if fucking worked we did it it works
okay so yeah but this is this is not the
sciquest this is the original Quest
this is the original Quest so this means I
got to read bring I got to bring vagrant
back the problem with our original Quest
this is not the quest yeah
wait what is it called
the machine with the name was not found
configure for bigger environment
we have to up at first
I've never I don't know how to do any of
this
I don't want to fall through so much with
her
do you do the bigger file or do you have to
have to be in my configuration in my head is
like totally fucked up now
all right well first things first let's
actually turn this guy off
as I don't need you anymore
I already added that
yeah I knew that the first time I ever do is
let me know you make me bring you back a lot
of memories here that we did that already
fitted
I could have swore I had in that
you know I did that it and I deleted it I'll
prove it I can look at the gate if they get
history here and I'll show you that it was
here we'd deleted it you know why yeah we
deleted it because it added it all that shit
moment I saw that remember
they were added all that shit when he saw
that I have it in the history also I'm
something
yeah it was there we ripped it out because
we we decided to abandon bigger so now we're
like look at it bigger and again and
considering some things
so
yeah I know I know what to do I know with
you we did it already
but I also want to make sure that we have
the completion of stuff in there
this is something I'm getting confused I
can't believe we're going back to this one I
really can't
I had to change my topic are
I can't believe this is back on the table
this is insane
live good morning
well this is been the week of vagrant
give him chemo and terraform ansible for
sure as soon as I can will win week
alright so to get this week and
how do you get to Fig I just need to open
this real quick and go show you that I did
it
Ashley Simms. Files
and I go look on the history on the. The
pastor see
history remove vagrant and never use it
again and Miguel
if vagrant then do this shit
just so fucking horrible
I guess we're running it back
satlink
all right this is back up spackle I've
apparently
I forgot steam but yeah
and we do need to do the export I didn't see
that in there I could have sworn we had that
in there
I at one point when I think happened yeah I
think I know what happened I had that
environment variable in here and that never
got committed and then I just wrote the
whole thing out before I got a chance to
committed so we'll go ahead and add it back
fragrance I know specifically because I was
looking forward
in I might have to kill this again today
nevermind
I'm just going to bite me in the ass God
damn it
I make sure it works so we do vagrant
fragrance up it is versabox again
sharing provision for you do you have every
right fragrant destroy
vagrants a fisherman
I just want to see if it uses every time box
by default in alavert provider has not found
that was that was requested
back machine places in front of that exist
it was not a big there's no bigger than a
provider
so this is the problem we had before part of
it I guess about the following providers
that's how he got his at work I don't ever
had at it at 8 when I can really pulling up
old stuff now
there it is Megan plug-in I think we deleted
all of it
I was a mistake I should have done that
I did give up on dig right like completely
in and it just it works
with virtualbox and now I
it brought up a vagrant no problem
everything is just said that was not a very
good looking and yet I just started the
other one so now I'm really freaking
confused
so yeah
I tried to just okay so we actually fixed we
fixed liver today
we fix it we got it to work the way it's
supposed to work there's a number of
configurations it's all documented in The
Zed and chunky help us figure that out
and it was it's not working so and then
we'll try to use the telephone it doesn't
work because the same
volume permission problem and
so that that didn't work it was like okay
it's it's it's the big one it's a provider
for living room
I mean I mean liver provider and then I
thought well maybe the thing that we fix
maybe the permissions are that we fixed
actually fixed the the vagrant issue
and so then we did vagrant
and I started in it it it works it seems it
was it guys from the cigarettes
oh I don't know liver cannot be found
Tubac the machine default music provider
they exist
some of that same problem now and now we're
back to
hey but I think was the original problem the
reason why you deleted the ignorant
all over again so it didn't fix anything you
can't use vagrant with chemo and the birds
it's like as a known bug and I feel like
we're back where we started from again I
think I thought I had a moment of Hope
because it was showing it was working but
I believe the reason for that was
only because hair wholesale
unset Big Red
is it default provider or something
is all the stuff with liver with a major
issues you can say that all you want it
doesn't mean it works
it works for your bullshit setup
yeah I was actually able to get it work
today after I talk to somebody else so I
mean after we wasted all that time the other
day I'm super happy to talk to somebody who
was going on so
and cuz we got it working right away and and
that was that give me that made me happy
that we may be able designated by the way
experienced all the same problems that I had
talked about every single one every single
one that's why they knew how to fix it so
yeah that's awesome I'm happy for you you
probably weren't using a
the fact the fact that matter is the person
who had this are the reported it
successfully and helped us get it fixed
successfully had had this problem on a bun
to and it was because it was about to say so
yeah I'm happy for you think that's awesome
you didn't help me the other day though and
somebody else figure it out so I don't know
man explained that to me mister hundred
million dollars sold company for
it works for me
we spent eight hours trying to fix it and
you couldn't fix it here and they fix it in
like an hour so I call bullshit
so app you can you tell you what Bruce in
the pudding so so this is a thing
that we didn't get working I'm also brand
new to the whole thing so that's always
something it's there
I don't give a shit about your receipts dude
we just want explanations at work
and we're all in there is trying to go there
trying to figure it out I appreciate your
help it's not like I'm going to run grateful
I just
I don't like ever hearing it works on my
computer I don't know what your problem is
do you not know not to say that ever
I know it works but I'm trying to tell you
if they got it to work exactly with the way
we needed to without anything different so
no you didn't you didn't you didn't want
suggest that I changed the group delivered
which fixed it not once and that's fine we
were experimenting we were going through
things but and I appreciate your help again
I said I appreciate your help but giving me
that works on my computer is going to piss
me off every time and you're going to get a
little going to get a little shit back for
me if you say that shit to me ever and that
goes for everybody else to sorry works for
me mad I know what to tell you
no I had to do my drinking nothing to do
that now you didn't tell me that I have all
the chat logs you really want me to pull
them up absolutely didn't complete it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter it works
okay I was just move on is he really don't
know what to do it right
if you don't if you don't know what to tell
me they don't do they say it works for me I
don't know the problems just keep looking
you know what I mean
I don't want to hear it from this asshole
for awhile by 4/4 minute
come back when you're useful God damn all
right so
I'm going to try I'm going to try to see if
we can get this Bennett make everything
working again
and we'll go ahead and go for it the
the difference is that we have delivered
that works now so I want to make sure we can
isolate that down and see if we can get that
I covered I don't know
what's your favorite commands are some
minutes remind myself of all those again I
don't want to use vagrant I really don't
it's an old technology I almost don't want
to do it and just keep focusing on the PM's
and go with it go that route and we'll get
that going
so
let's see what is the shopping list commands
what's the one that showed us all her stuff
that sub
Xbox right vagrant box
list there you go
so there we got it actually it actually it
actually opened up a generic live this is
something that happened today
and I don't believe this is the one that got
that weed that we brought up I don't know
though I'm going to go ahead and try that
yeah how are you going to be
so if you do bigger than it again in scratch
to have an event file I think that's
probably going to do
yeah vagrant file
this file was free empty
it doesn't have much in there let's go ahead
and start from scratch actually I think I
want to be really careful with is to make
sure that the boxes
the boxes that are listed as being up are
not boxes that were brought up using the
working virt-manager situation and I think
that that's might be the case I think that
this might have been the one that was popped
up by the ignorant that maybe the one that
was started
so so that might be the way to go on that
it's let's do that let's go for it let's say
that's what I think we need to delete all of
these
I think it's interesting that the four-door
one came up as well let's let's let's try to
destroy them all from being her and see
what's up so we can do a clean vagrant and
thing completely
ignorant destroy
it's not fair. I don't know how to do this
so I'm going to figure this out just to do
the completion for you
do you have the second do you have to have a
referral for it right I'm not created
I remember how to do bigger and it deletes
improve for the virtualbox yeah I know I
don't know how to do that
I don't know. We'll figure it out yes
regular destroy I need to be discreet about
it
straight sh give me the institutions that
directory or the ones that are in the
directory
that makes me wonder where the others went
and where they came from
is it safe to say I don't know but it is
safe to say that it's listing boxes that are
there that we're not under big
responsibility before right I think that's
what's happening
it's box vagrant box and if so is it remove
okay good I want to do it explicitly though
and you have a VM pray to just the box
images
okay so we have this is for staying so this
only shows two boxes under management from
virtualbox I mean from
I see that that removed it with the liver
provider which you know what makes me wonder
so
if we try the other one and see
that's supposed to leave select a single
provider to remove with provider
access multiple providers multiple providers
interesting
I did not know that help me find
all right so now we probably going to have
problems adding it because of the whole
limbert setup even though I added the plugin
for Lindbergh
so we're going to check that vagrant
box list they're not sell boxes okay
fragrant Vox ad oops
I'll try we need to give it a provider right
I see a man with a bigger box add name URL
or path
okay let's do a generic 20 2010 actually
yeah this is where we get the list of them
right
generic
I want to we look that up on it we look that
up I was like going back a couple days but
this is what we did we looked it up on the
big old list of images of ignorant provides
and I want to has multiple providers nice
let's see if we can get this when they work
so far so good cross your fingers please
work please work
the plugins installed you know what the plug
and you know what the plug-in went in
I think we had an error I don't remember I
didn't document it but I think we're in an
area with a plug-in going in so
it I'm going to shop
heckling comparing the check Sons
this is like really good news because we
think we got this is already way too far
then we got before that is fantastic
holyshit the vagrant thing is probably going
to work for us like everybody says now that
we got the liver thing fixed so I don't
commands that it's cool no taking system I
have to do it because if I don't do it on
fucking die
I make so many mistakes in as everybody has
noticed I make that I have to go back and
look at things in Creative boxing just
images yes boxers are images of bn's are are
bringing something up right so now we can
actually do a vagrant file and there's
nothing in this thing this is just as it was
in the net this was just a bigger than that
the only thing we changed it is the box type
that was the it wouldn't put Internet
working on there or anything such as ansible
so let's go for this and
I think we should be able to do a leg up and
weight using the maker of pilots in our
current directory I think I'm going to try
it
and if it brings up a system we are golden
and and then I'll be using bacon for all
this shit which means I'll have to learn
Ruby as long as it works this is the reason
for this the main reason for this is because
we we just concluded that terraform cannot
be used without a cloud which means you have
to have a cloud and even if the cloud is
local like you know openstack or proxmox or
whatever you have to make your own probably
some way to cheat and get around that but
that is the that is the you know, and
supported way of using to reform which makes
sense that's what is at school it's her form
is for provisioning servers in the cloud or
machines in the club that's what it's for
it's always been that so trying to make it
do it on a single machine only if the
machine look like a cloud is kind of
cheating and not really well supported
vagrant does that well when it works it just
was not working
play because of the liver problem which the
all the bugs that we found and then they
were confirmed and then we got to fix today
so now that we have lived behaving
properly I think we might be off and running
on vagrant and Bighorn is the most common
thing you're going to hear about on YouTube
because it's so fucking old I don't
particularly like writing Ruby files for my
configurations but and but if it works so be
it
importing the bass box that looks like it
did virtualbox instead of the bird
is it because I didn't provision it live God
damn it brushing machine yet
I thought we had liver down there
yeah it is if it if it's using the
virtualbox provider and it and I can't get
liver to work within 10 minutes then because
this was supposed to be a test to see if
Lambert worked I'm just going to stick with
her Suboxone, and I don't give a shit and
that's what Tony while I was betting that I
was going to end up doing in the end anyway
and I think he was right or they were right
I don't really even know who people so let's
try that sostre
I did is because I unset that environment
variable fuck I think it is oh you know what
it was damn it I had to unset the
environment variable in order to get to
destroy and down file and down stuff to work
the command to work because it was it was
saying it wasn't a valid provider and now
now we need to bring it back up so I'm going
to have to pull out all this all that stuff
back down again so that's good just practice
big wrench
list snacks with Megan Fox list right
it's going to say Virgil box there at pulled
both down though why did it pull both of
them down
oh wait a second
wait a second
I'm thinking here I am I am
covid grants
who is it called I got them and I remember
Pastor C
a lighter make sure they can file does not
contain virtualbox search for imprimatur
give me Waze best yes I'm trying to commute
I turn it up to a boy
I want to know is there a way to prove to
put that specifically in your neighborhood
file
yes it does yep it definitely does
what are using apparently you can
wasn't saving up provider is it be ended up
earlier if you beat up for better
configuration at work public I don't know
anything about bigger files so
there it is if a Korean provider Russian box
to do BB
I agree cuz true or Suboxone Resorts cutie
with a booty machine no allowed to take and
pick her up for a provider
and it works against a folder or no
I don't know if it's just the environment
variable or not I want to look for something
more precise besides environment variable
their default provider
why isn't it doing it if have vagrant
is there okay so why
hey Grinch amazing running
covers of ice for sale.
I tried to tell you make a note make a call
to shut down for Thalia can you bring her to
spend any case we start again step in the
mirror up vagrant
halt it's a great social 7 p.m.
is that it being provider Levert you found
it
thank you so much for finding that I just
wanted to fuck around with environment stuff
you know I asked people to say they would
namespace is kubernetes I hated I hate it
I like to set it explicitly in Miami files
because I don't I don't I don't want to
accidentally get over it and buy something
you know
yeah I need to go to the whole crate bigger
thing I do I do I'm just I'm kind of rushing
this little bit
hey G provider that led verts so
let's try this
I mean if if this works it shouldn't give a
shit about the variable
and it should blow up honestly I got to be
prepared for the Super Bowl
I don't I don't necessarily
I mean I can see arguments both ways okay
using that allows you to
using that allows you to change a virtual
machine and have things come up it's
probably more innocent people can swap out
their provider I get it but but
while I'm doing this right now I want to be
absolutely sure what I'm dealing with and
their RC is still went for virtualbox so
that would mean it's not reading the Big
File
War or it's not raining my environment
variable either one is not working
it's a ruby scope it's a Rubik's Cube for
very variable
yeah yes
look I just the environment variable is not
being recognized I type something wrong
perhaps but it's not working
so vagrant underscore defaults underscore
provider
equals live Bird right when I do vagrant up
if that's true then I should be able to
haven't pick up that one
and it says it says it's doing your default
virtualbox it doesn't just fucking ignores
environment variable I completely straight
up and doors it what am I missing
yeah so yeah configured I see you have it
outside
options for live at making provider to live
holy shit
live liver driver KVM
oh my God this looks phenomenal kind of wish
I had this years ago this is awesome
I've been trying to find this stuff is this
in the big stuff and example boxes try to do
this again
yeah yeah I see it here too it's in here
here's a here's the thing okay so let me
know before I dismiss this the suggestion to
use the environment variable is not working
and I need to be absolutely sure that
because I'm seeing documentation of this as
well that that's the way you should be able
to do it and it's to me it's not working so
we already know they got tons of bugs
because we see them documented from the
other stuff we were doing so what I want to
do is I'm going to try to be you no more
meticulous on this because I want to isolate
the bugs and things at work and if things
don't work so because if we're going to be
dealing with maker and it's going to be a
pain in the ass and I want to make sure it's
documented that the first thing is this this
does not work I can copy and paste that
right now I can put it into environment
variable and I can do vagrant up
and it will big bring up a little box
instead of anything else is that because
that particular one has already been
admitted that way I don't know if we take me
to get rid of the vagrant file here and you
vagrant an it you know what is that do
bigger fountain place so you do make and we
do this give you the base box and everything
I mean what's not even fucking touch the
thing and see what it does if this doesn't
work I want to know why okay so and so far
it hasn't you know I against the expert that
file just some people believe me export
bigger files was literally copied and
pasted. Vagrant
I do have a dog bacon file but this
all right let's just delete that shit
you change the provider on the fly it would
take Francis is the vagrant file well I
didn't see anything to Patron file so all
right let's start with 00 they renewed
srf.ch vagrant let's remove the vagrant file
vagrant file and and then we have we have no
vagrant here and then let's actually just
like do the thing really removing I don't
think we need to do that though right
the vagrant list it'll say
we only have liver and liver box which is
fine and then we have
what was it was the other thing
we need to remove some of the stuff is so
let's do I think it's status right
environment or Target machine is required to
run this command Undertaker in it so it
doesn't know about anything right now let's
I'm a manager and make sure nothing is
running that's kicking Flex with it
because I sometimes wonder nope nothing is
there so there is no virtual machines
running right now as far as we know so then
I mean virtualbox might have some suffering
but I wouldn't know
so let's do this let's do they rent in it
and the question is do I need to put the
provider in here I probably do right
and just to be sure let's do provider equals
Lindbergh and see I don't I don't know if
that's a thing well as try that doesn't like
it that last time so Mason has been placed
in your right a and that has there's no
other vagrant files in here there's nothing
here go ahead and exit the Box again
expert that says copy and paste from the
site to go back to the site over here
and if we do
so there's to call my sister this next to
the test that we did we did that very test
and it didn't work
and let's try I mean we did it we did a
basic one
vagrant file let's change this to be it was
a generic
generic Ubuntu 2010
all right so now we have generic a bunch of
2010 and we should be able to pick her up
and that she grabbed it now this is the air
we got before it didn't know about live
Birds
and this is where the question comes in do
we have to install the plugin
please use a provider that exists so this
does not know about the plug in for Levert
and I don't know how to make it know about
the plug-in if so
is this this look at that the document hair
that you guys had
for the telephone when I get to take a peek
yeah I think the closest one to
alright so here we go ahead and projects
created locally
provider options should work through this
supposed to cut a few versus conditions
how long are things
this is a fake this fuss this rice just wife
Sheriff's if you they could fix if you said
there they have
provider do I got that phone number for that
other
but I don't there's there is no could not be
found right
I wonder if I have to do another stanza for
it or something
we need to read about how to get delivered
support and I don't think it's in here
they might be in the top. Let me go look
vagrant Levert provider all right I'll see
if I can get it installed and read it all
take a look at open issues in container
image
Ken around compatibility with Ruby runtime
environment is full stream
you're connecting to remote system Lynn
Ranch Nashville
what I want to use a container when they
Point container images to use the vagrant
that's weird crane image it's possible to
find
a function for example vagrants Alberta
Falls your eye vagrants the birds
why would you put it in a Docker container I
can't imagine doing that
I don't understand why they would do that
extending the doctor images additional
Varian plugins
human liver install if you're planning
revenge on your local system for
instructions use this note because you're
starting to because you start using vagrant
liver please make sure your liver and kidney
installation is working correctly and you're
able to create chemo and KVM type person
machines with yes and I have already done
that
I did that yet
next year must have Negron installed vagrant
Levert supports vagrant to it should also be
easier things just are the current list of
test versions
vagrant version
2.2 and 90k
I need to make you need to make sure you
have all the bill dependencies installing a
bigger the verge
we have all these we have them cuz we did
this already
open Susie Arch Linux Fedora possible
problems with plugin installation on Linux
he's had problems with building NOCO girl
which was the problem we had
we didn't have that problem with that
specific problem
bigger than beds dnf downloads bigger
project preparation add box
I still don't see the instructions for how
to install it
it doesn't say how to install the bug in
there's like a million different things and
none of them
there it is okay Pac-Man fedora
you're now ready to install using vagrant
plugin installation methods for some of the
citruses you need to figure out a
configuration works
extreme okay so let's try this I I did this
already
and apparently that only installs it into
your current directory I think that's what
we lost I think that's what we lost
I think since those are in a local that
vagrant directory I think that's what's
going on see a brownie brownie
I'm going to be going to bed here soon
pretty soon hey I got in it got no girls
find oh my God that makes me happy
I did not get that last time it did not get
it as well
so it's going to get that
building native extensions that makes me
wonder what it's doing my fans on Tanya
though so she'll probably be okay
yep yep
if there we go this is this is
I think this is the problem we had last time
I don't know maybe not
vagrant failed to properly resolved required
dependencies users can call me because I
miss configure plug installation or Transit
reports are blah blah blah
at daycare
I'm never going to hit Sarasota sell brand
new stuff yeah I threw myself into terraform
ansible
Isabel vagrant KVM and chemo all in 3 days
this is what you get
this is got a ton of dependencies that are
not being satisfied this is typical you know
stuff
it so we can have to do maybe in an hour
I don't understand this thing but if I'll
damage published in use contains the entire
tool chain required to reinstall bigger than
a plug-in NES dependencies and this is the
default behavior of anytime when you plug it
isn't so it's means it should be possible to
use a simple from saving a speaker to
install additional plugins
I just don't make any sense I this looks
like they they bundled up all of their stuff
all of their dependencies into a Docker
container to avoid all the Ruby shit so that
it would just work
yeah I see what they're doing here huh
interesting
you think remember to Ken around
compatibility with rubber runtime
environment this is part of the Upstream
Baker insulation and the library
dependencies that this project requires to
communicate with the birds in other words
because Ruby is a piece of shit that this is
a darker image build that there is a darker
image build and publish
RV dumps in a ravine virtual a mess with
their doing yeah like my van and I know I
actually this this is probably the best way
to do this yeah yeah this should allow you
to text you vagrant with liquor in Liberty
without needed to deal with it compatibility
issues though you may need to extend the
image Briones should you make additional
used to the plug-in that this is your fault
and you should change the filter change
required to build this all the big red lid
and it's dependencies
there is also a smaller image publish with
the slim side effects if you just need
vagrant Laverne and don't need to assign
ages to plug is your moment if you are
connecting to a remote system Levert You may
omit Dash Envy Mountain behind some
distribution specialist actually sounds like
a good idea now that I know I don't know
about darker look better
so dr. Pol yeah
running the image the real the real Slim
vagrant
to get the image of the most recent released
a couple of LED vagrant they they can't live
vert vagrant Dash The Verge latest that if
you want the very latest you can get Edge
running the image shit
indoctrinate Atlas rise
I really want to try this I think this I
think this is a better way to go because I
understand doctor now that are in and I
think it's probably going to go
where's the doctor in June with religious
yeah it's really not dashed privilege said
yeah I'm guessing
yeah it's it has to be able to get yeah
I don't know if that's safe but you know
it's probably nice
because I would rather you look I don't mind
if they keep maintaining ancient Ruby ship
as long as they give us containerized
version and they did so I feel like I should
that's the right thing for me to do is use
that probably also don't have to walk around
with all this stuff either if we do this I
mean I mean for completion I guess I have to
do that but
so if they Grant
vagrant Okay so
I can do this thing where I automatically to
text Megan
now it go I'm going to put this in the in
Star this is something that might be able to
assistant that I might be able to get behind
and not be upset about because it is old
Tech I don't mind learning a little Ruby
again
you know
ain't nobody covered privileged in their in
their their stuff here I would have guessed
they would have put that shocks for a lift
chair but they didn't
so I don't know vagrant
so
I like Ruby I just yeah I like it I just
feel like it's kind of running out of time
and interpret language is always have the
problem like the one we just head I mean you
don't have this problem with you even with
her for me real good and if you have a nose
no problem as soon as we got to the binary
no Estetica compiled by owners are so much
easier to work with
Arabic number for the I know I love a ruby
Community I love the Ruby Community even
especially months
oh I know I agree the Ruby Community has
been
has been hands-down the most accommodating
friendliest Community I've ever had to work
with
yep and they do not stand officer really I
think it's set by Matsumoto when he's just
so amazing I really like the really
Community I always have it's it's just that
you know
I don't know ISO vagrant
list
you met him here is Mormonism I don't know
if he's still as it was in 2017 was
yeah I tried a little bit once not in person
but
yeah and really inspired me to make the pro
classes pregnant make turn pro in a ruby
I just read something I wanted you to say
yes exactly
yeah he's he's I like him a lot like a
moment I try to get everybody to do it in
fact it was because of Ruby that I found out
about second life because I was looking for
a way to do virtual meet-ups because I
didn't want to travel an hour to go to
really meet up let me tell that story before
but I meant that that's what I did and I
went to my first the first thing I ever went
to in Second Life was a ruby meet up because
I was learning about how to code in but I
like we was so much better than python
I do but I haven't written it in a long time
you know it's funny because rust has a lot
of syntax elements from premature all the
languages including Ruby and I think it's
interesting
every computer with my Honda out wasn't the
same space
if it was a really great for making demands
specific languages is it was Fantastic Four
that still is
head-to-head I don't think it was
head-to-head with my phone the different
thing
it is Ruby and pearl knotheads a little bit
but that was always they were always
complementary of each other
did it in LA I really hope I don't explode
that stuff really wasn't even python python
has been better at at doing C+ at disguising
sea than any other language so far that's
what makes python famous my phone is really
good at hiding
at hiding C plus plus
it's it's okay like it's all the credit when
it's actually see plus plus that's get
that's that that's the reason that people
use it
are bees in action of pro which is why the
entire Metasploit database is designed to
use it
so maybe I should just accept it I'll try to
sell this to vagrant
box list
vagrants I don't know now that her can't
find it still
so I can't find it doesn't make any sense
Prince Road am that's why
Batman there we go oh my God it did it oh my
god it worked
it's only a holy cow wait a second
filter initialize KVM device or resource
busy why
Isis Mysteries was cuz it was it was already
something there they already have something
there
wow
can I see resource busy kuna system nice
resource busy
I wouldn't say that
oh man we're getting so close
we're definitely getting closer
oh like if he was going to crash I sent it
to this a crash
I see how it is all the stuff's going away I
was VM stuff is like killing it
python wants to be a one obvious way but it
really isn't us too bad it never really
filled that promise
everything was all I was in between Ruby was
a pearl anyway you want kind of thing
to win out yep I think it might I think
versus Wolverine so much just fucking works
you know
yeah I got to get shit done and I got to do
it tomorrow so I don't have time to fuck
around with all this other stuff
order me to yeah yes it absolutely was
completely agree especially accessories and
get ours as cool as they were don't make any
sense
yeah it's it's this is not good I probably
have to reboot at this point
Caribbean Caribbean failed 16 device
resource midi how is the device resource
busy there's no resource
I don't see
I don't know I just don't see I just don't
see it working
I mean let's be realistic the only reason I
was using liver and cute chemo is because
it's so fucking fast it's so much faster
than than than virtualbox
the versabox just works you know
that's actually prove that I bought this is
Kelly so
I'm going to I'm going to rip it out again
yeah I don't know
initiate number to fill out your eye
wait what are the fault that aren't your
ideas because we
aren't your ID because you didn't Define
delivered about your eye
oh no that's just an extended right
out let's get rid of this guy
exact
hey current up and got passed a bunch of
other things besides problems
give me some more information now is it
today starting to Maine
can you call to the main crate with flags
failed
turn alarm processing look connected to
monitor I have to give him create failed
device or resource busy
how to initialize KVM device or resource
busy
that's it that's it that's an air coming
from the chemo system so if we had actually
tried to build it with you or system it
would have failed to
so that's what they were saying hey make
sure we're so we can keep him if we hit this
is one of the commands from Kimmy for come
up for critics up by the fall from the from
ground up
is Deb to him already yeah I don't know what
it is but we got to figure out
what it what is it that's what it'll tell
you it is it is it l s i o
it's so if I think it right
he's poor. We might need a rebate I could
have fought this Colonel and pretty bad
I need to find out what's got that what's
got that baby I'm open already yeah
many could be any number of things in this
point
how to
how can I just give him with the number
Andrews I think that might be a part of the
two is it doesn't have privileged access we
might have to add dash dash privilege to
Hood
if I want to create a group C KVM it could
be many Cube it could be
I need you to season by default so I don't
know any chance you have to be home by a
group.
2 2 2 2 2 2
is there is a member of the KVM in living
room group
wait I don't think I know because it ran the
process is 1,000
and so is Francis a thousandis 1000 / the
KVM group you need to launch a new shell
why do we have to ask ourselves a KVM rube
this is real it's real I'm going to your
user session buy snow cone machines
shaver missions
arkadium yeah that's the problem I'm not in
the KVM group
I don't think I am nope I don't remember me
having it be an issue though but obviously
it is
kbm is your name
I whoops this is an old one
that's not how I normally do it I don't know
what these are might as well isn't it a g
I don't remember
I don't reason one I can about a stage
components home Directory Group
is it a g
i could have swore I did that before I guess
not
say yes do do do do do do
su Studio Su Dash thanks Rob
all right I mean it's going to be harder to
get this way him up
Sealab vagrant
different error this is a resource is busy
how to initialize coronavirus for the same
error busy
insufficient for Missions I don't know why
you would ever do that
message it's it is busy it's not that I
can't get access to it different
I don't know how ice
busy
Southern industrious of you is just enough
is being done to have a magically going to
KVM you stop the other hypervisor or use
being driver to switch.
Mini Cube see I think maybe he was fucking
it up
I think it is and that would be the reason
is not working
I kind of want to get it off of here
team profiles I got doctor stuff front it's
all darker it should not be a problem
I don't have anything that uses let's not
your grip memberships
I added it to yayeah
I think alien doctor in the brat now
please stop the other half a razor or use it
to switch it Kim does not
there's that there's never a hypervisor that
stuck them have to reboot to get this to fix
it
she has a severe strain reservations for
your failed
us mod in Grand Canyon
give him and tell him and tell him
assumption National nibbled Frisco Colorado
let me know I sent it says I hope
Amber Argentina is your butt still working
and I promise live at mattresses that
doesn't exist camera system
this is really hard but I don't know how to
say is it is it two dashes or is it three
dashes
is it two dashes or was it three dashes
emu best Caribbean
NFL
how are you
can't refuse
huh
s almost like he will hasn't been installed
Ameri doesn't make any sense higher Napa wow
it's good photo
how far away it looks like a total photo I
know I love it it's beautiful it's a doggy
so it's so well done
because it sucks in
it is it's really pretty oh I like how it
builds up the edges that's really cool
make s a border without a border
I understand what this is says I tried to
say we were salvation of symbiosis
a certain logic abmd
security sensor that makes me wonder if
virtualbox is using it already
is there any is there any way we're supposed
to be running right now
disturbing you when you doing is my I sent a
picture
it looks like it's embedded in there
it doesn't look at does it does not look
like pain at all it looks like a painting I
mean I mean photograph
at the photograph I love it
the kernel modules running yeah okay so I
got to try something here
yeah there we go
Deputy warnings are there any other night
did you see that one oh yeah
let's do something crazy
it's about my computer is totally dying cuz
Papa less you see how it's completely
shutting out because it sucks it sucks its
populace has got all kinds of bugs the
latest one especially I can't even see what
I'm typing in my desktop manager anymore
thank God for us keys
it's it's absolute shit I cannot wait to get
back to Mint
sitting here going to go ahead and do that
and
I'll go for it hey there
so we're going to do
I mean I got versabox on here are we going
over some blocks
I think the new version has been released oh
goodie
okay that we that Library current default is
running
it says it's running that's why I couldn't
start the other one
and it might be because it still thinks it's
trying to use the other one I don't know you
know
so
yeah
I kind of want to turn it off and just make
a new distro from scratch and I wouldn't
have all these problems
I think that might be what's causing the
problem yeah
I need to turn this thing off I can't even
turn it off apparently I had a login though
machine pause
front for us Pokemon eating I can make an
operating system
thanks for the vote of confidence yeah I'm
you know what I threw myself at a ton of
stuff this weekend and all it is destroying
my ego is so much I learned so much but but
yeah I'm going to try to learn ansible
terraform vagrant Kimu KVM
all in 4 days 3 days
classy handful of people have been telling
me to travel to me as well I mean but at
least I'll know what people talk about when
you know when they yell at me when I yell
and I say hey I don't know I'm doing any say
Hey try this tonight okay
I feel confident this is going to work
slightlyis it going to work slightly better
so far so good
so far that was it I feel sort of hopeful
I feel sort of hopeful holy shit there were
no errors
oh my God
this is why I like being hackers
the greatest Hair Force you can do and be
good at almost everything is just a minute I
know you could you can't do it anymore. I
know what this feels like it's like you feel
like you have your handling something in
there like 10 other things that are like
it's super Annoying It's too I know exactly
what you're saying
it was just a habit
got you know what you was going to suck as
it's going to actually
well no because it did appendices is still
needed to resolve those so
now I just now just makes you want to try
Tara from a law firm
yeah it's so different I mean you kind of
knew what was going on before
it's something like that I work on cars to
Nike I remember my Dodge Dart when I knew
where the alternator was I can just take it
out and replace it when I go to bed and I
have no fucking idea to take my whole engine
and part cuz technology people
if you want I can do it I can do it if
Chewbacca can do it I can do it
I mean I feel like there's something here
now I don't know what it is
I don't know how to get to it it's there
make a list how's it going polar
anyway
let's do this let's do
isn't there like an SSH think there is yes
yes there is
hey look look it connected holyshit
I have an Ubuntu 2010 suit machine I want to
learn kubernetes so do I
I really do and I've been doing it for a
Full Bucket year I still want to learn it
I've already know the different kinds of
mine Orchestra ways can I say that I know it
even though I've been a professional. It
adds up to you man
you can view it's like I have a level 1
knowledge of it whenever I think you just
need to be precise right it's working so so
our vagrant lab Tunes up tends to be the
late in the winter most of the shit I need
to do is falls under vagrant and that saves
me from you I will still use terraform and
all that stuff but not before this
and this shit what you bring up yet and
bring up with him whatever you want to drink
whenever you can do straight that's probably
right in that a dance of operations to the
bank and file which you can do you get a
chance of a provision so that I can file
and this apparently figuring is old Tech
though so I don't know how much to invest in
this but I definitely am going to
I guess I could with two machines in this
rain what was the one there's like a vagrant
command it's like
realist the status
shit oh I know why
even if he's not going to work
is there a movie
vagrants
. was that their private
call find a whole bunch of proficient 5 on
ya
because I had no idea what they've done you
know you got to be able to talk about it
I can tell you exactly what I know about
Mega right now
I was just very much we can say can I say am
I do I know if bacon yes enough to bring up
a single thing you know and that's not
sufficient for most purposes
I I need to I need the ansible this guy big
time
I do I do I delete all this other shit in
here my life
and if you are very angry confirms his
version
I'm not going to comment below for complete
reference to go to Doc's are they grown up
everything and Val envirocars inbox is there
two boxes I am kind of glad that this that I
don't have to throw back or not completely
because of this is definitely the tool that
was targeted at what I wanted to do which is
pull up a bunch of GM's in order to software
testing noguchi drewski
God..... Disable automatic updating
next steps vagrant provisioning did you find
me link you're such a good person thank you
for that
if they going to file
trainer box configure the box with ansible
yeah I'm going to include that in here
no plugins no plugins no plugins plugins can
die
nope
all right
you're not really like about that when I ran
that it told me exactly what the error was
every other time I tried to do this I had no
idea what the other was
and I really appreciate that that was
something I don't know where that came from
but I I noticed that sad just when we ran
the dockerfile when we did the doctor
container we got a lot more information
about what was going wrong
and and I feel like that's where their
efforts are focused so I kind of want to
keep doing that ready for the live Birds
thing
it's all I saw kbm Kimu plus live Birds
another project another lab for that
make sure you fix all of her issues
and so vagrant for Linux
I kind of think we should just say we should
just do the docker file assault
install vagrant for Linux Docker image
and make these bald so
docker if if you haven't already
give me a work it's been a long painful
Journey Tony
I don't know if I can suggest you watch the
whole thing if you want the highlights I can
give you those backed up probably do a video
of my summary of all the learning
suffice it to say
vagrant vagrant sold as a ton of Reba
dependencies
and it doesn't play nicely with Levert and
Ubuntu also has a ton of problems with
libvirt so I'm going to give you a few
things that might help you out the first
thing is if I did this over again
I would
I don't know but I would probably is ready
on the difference the problem though is if
you want to use this stuff on your local
system you have to use the vert and you have
to use a bunch of probably either that or
Archer maybe Arch doesn't have the same
problems I don't know people use artes they
are used to these kind of problems so
if
I don't think I'm ready I don't think I'm
ready to throw out my desktop workstation
and use red hat or Cento us as my go-to
daily driver I just it's just not set for
set up for that I don't think I would want
to do that and all of the problems I had a
lot of them was with Bert would have been
avoided if I had so that means you have to
go there getting his chemo and liver liver
instead of just the average person who wants
to use bacon is just going to use virtualbox
to be done right to the beginners out there
this is what I would suggest install
virtualbox cuz you need it no matter what
Universal box anyway right most of the time
you need. I said just works and it's just
very easiest very beginner friendly and you
just download an ISO and you play around
with all your different Linux distros get
that skill make sure you can do that that's
good because you can try our child you can
try you know any history want and I'll draw
Elemental as you can try them all out and
see which one you want so that still have
used a whole box of the thing the next
schedule after that that I will I'm going to
talk about the infrastructure Engineering in
the boots in that would be to run in a
distance darker would be to run a vagrant
using so they can is like hey you remember
all the stuff we did with the gooey let's go
do it from the command line you can do it
from the virtualbox command line or you can
use vagrant and we're going to use that
instead because the vagrant command line is
going to be reusable for other providers as
well and then the third steps at 3 would be
probably write this down the third step is
anything that that uses histrionics it's my
daily driver yet
it's so that the third thing would be okay
now let's Leo so use the ultra-fast an ultra
crew or cool chemo and KVM on the local
system and let's combine that as a provider
for vagrant and that would be the third
thing and then that would be an introduction
to KVM and chemo and why you would use it so
actually I got to write this down because I
just want to
introduction to virtualization
so this is me my my normal route it was B
install virtualbox
and get a it's over to box
install Windows
into a VM set up a Windows VM
set up a Linux VM in virtualbox
set up a about this one too set up
an arch set up
a red hat maybe try Suzy
and these aren't these are kind of things
right and then what I would try
a set up a
send a virtual box VM from at using vagrants
I install vagrant
at using vagrant
install KVM Kimu
linford's
Lynn words G
and set up I can figure
and then what then I would say
set up a set up a live Birds
set up set up a liver VM using vagrant no
setup
set up and then
verts yam is a virtual manager
I said living room using make ranch
solve a grant as Docker container
and said Liberty in using a vagrant
container
set up multiple
yams at the same time using a crunch
and then configure
multiple vlans with ansible
combines with vagrants
head out goodnight baby buddy but animals do
not want to
yep for sure
and those are really expecting me to know
the ins-and-outs of your daddy's maybe they
are
so yeah
here's what I suggest
to get your head around all that is possible
with virtual ization
I was going to keep adding so install
several physical servers at home
combined physical servers with proxmox
hey thanks for that I feel servers withwords
with frocks locks or something
set up several
GM's using Salt Air form
plant nursery rhymes using terraform pointed
at physical
when did that proxmox so this is all stuff I
want to do
so that I need to do more immediately than
others
so I mean that's going to get you started I
guess
yeah
can Aloha salon
so there we go
and we go through that
2 2 2 2 2 Foot Locker
so vagrant container
don't need the plug-in if you do the
container inspiring
thank you for saying so I need that right
now
I don't feel very inspiring but whatever
so hey Ya
or Nick's on two
alright so
Rena Al hemerson machine with Lindbergh
provider create a
create
yeah actually we don't even need to do the
pole
okay focus is firing me or should I just
this is for my survival so I can go through
in search of Molino
i c i I do all these things so that I can go
back and remember and I just searched
through my stuff when I need to you know and
if some of those benefits then so be it
right
the ansible add hot commands and we're
really cool I'm so glad that that turned out
to be a thing I did learn ansible tonight I
mean enough for me to move on and say I know
I know it enough to be dangerous pretty big
a machine with a fact that's the next step I
feel like I feel like we're kind of at a
stopping point I don't want to do something
fun tonight as well
as well
at me this is been fun it's just been really
hard on my soul so if you're in the box and
we have so I think I think we're back at the
vagrant
and I don't even think we need to change the
way bigger and file delivered any more we
don't need you then
so so yeah
yep and I think we have a machine
and I think I can ssh what do we call it
I think we can do SSH
and that's going to give me access to it
there we go
I do feel like
yeah we're just on the server right just a
basic server yeah it SSH is into your
current server and that crazy
I feel like I can because this is managed by
live bird I think I can use this to I think
I could just do this
I can absolutely can I didn't tell me what
my password was though
no I didn't even give me one that's super
interesting so vagrant does Issa stage
passwords
as if I did password let me try this so I
can do
password as I can figure a way to send even
if it doesn't have a user
oh yeah it doesn't even have a user I wish
it
so yes it was so that's super interesting so
that means when
listen so Megan is totally going to change
this is all bullshit
it is almost you're not doing any of this
I'm not doing any of this
this is all bulshit for reference
best way to do this so far is to do the very
first thing I recommend
and there it is right there that is how he
was a good old doctor huh I mean this is
like a real solid example of why darker
matters so strongly
and and that's all I have to say about that
in fact I'm going to CD back into my. Files
and we going to my installer and I'm going
to exchange vagrants
they move it I did did
that should stall vagrants smocks install
vagrants
vagrants Ben Bosch
Echo
do you know add function
they are not telling us
measure C we can do this thing to say
type vagrant
run that you're bash and we get the output
there we go
single thing
it always puts tabs into I don't like that
if you're doing remote ones you don't need
itremote ones you don't need it so we are
however using
real passing of you need me to be D it's all
need
continuations Network host
that's supposed to be quoted you bad coders
I think I am ADD install vagrant
alright so how fast RC commit
add back vagrant
vajtuse container
all right that that is excellent news I do
still have to relearn you know some Ruby and
stuff
but who gives a shit don't need to worry
about that
I was looking at some additional Fuller to
the guests we have the first argument is a
path so you can actually synchronize the
folder so you can put it vagrant file
inside of something that you want to
initialize like with a with a bachelor
seniors and all that kind of stuff
and password for bigger boxes I did not know
that tell her that it's nice okay good to
know
I'm I'm going to take all the stuff out that
I don't need
God dammit is it end yeah I'm going to get
good at Ruby again
I forgot you could do that would be high
yeah I found some time if you don't want to
use a shipping line
you can do that which this is not designed
to have anyting Romanian it
out status statues
alright so I'm getting this too far I can
put it to bed
private key why didn't put my private key in
there
gets restore
staged. Vagrants
I think there's like a standard maker and
ignore file right
getting Nora I mean
can't ignore
vagrant status
ignore commit
add working
they think rents Lynn birds with container
image
status Game Force
I don't think I tagged that one no what's a
vagrant
so here it is is my steps and all my links
ortholinks Aaron different things it
oh shit is not in his
I was going to put these in here I don't
have time to fuck with it
all right I I feel good right so tomorrow
tomorrow to work day
the first thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to write a vagrant file to bring up
3 GM's
when I was going to be the control plane one
of them is going to be an external server
and one of them is going to be a node
and on the external server I'm going to
install a singer and all of its dependencies
postgres and everything on the Node
well I don't care about the note we just
have to know to be the node I'm going to run
to Cuba ATM to do the insulation in the DM's
without using node that using a kind
I'm actually super excited about that
because I've never done it
and that should get me pretty far if not if
I want to add redundancy I can do that Henry
Carpenter Settles
I just searched everything
I saw a group or whatever so here's
everything I ever wrote about zettelkasten
right there
it's an aerosol built-in to get him
you get a free localized personal search
engine and get him for free that's the
reason I haven't rented it as a web page
because I don't want to fucking around with
Google and wait forever for Google to index
it I get him in almost immediately and it's
immediately visible most I can also just get
grab the thing and I know if you noticed but
I put all of my chat transcript in there as
well so I can if I want to see when I talked
about something on a given day I can go back
and find it so I really like that that's
just all come in come up that's all come
about because of a necessity really it's not
something I ever like you know consciously
thought about it just it's just right you
know you know it's off it's just a bunch of
read me files and get them the greatest
power from it comes from its Simplicity and
if I want to pull out of it if I want to
pull out like a website where I want to put
which I am going to do or go out I need to
make a nap cuz I'm the one downside of the
whole system right now is it if I am away
from my computer I have to have no way to
enter
you know what your date or anything it's
over the way I do that as I take a piece of
paper with me to write on it or I take my
phone and I talk into it but if I could talk
into an app on my phone and have it update
my little castle and get him that would be
the best and I will make that eventually
just a matter of time
so we're going to be a now know where we are
but I need to learn of EMS this is it this
is a matter of necessity so I have got to
learn to that how to do DM's because of the
ends are one of the few ways you can blow
something up
right so the ends are we on our way for you
to like destroy the universe without
destroying anything you cannot do that with
docker
so in case anybody is wondering where is
this you know where is interested bm2 coming
out from all the sudden I had
a tasket work which was ultimately check the
the the disc you know ization for a position
volume which is already hard enough and and
that means it implies being able to fill a
desk are getting pretty close and see what
happens when you fill it in that led me to
conclude that there that I can't do that in
kind which uses Docker to emulate a
kubernetes environment is not a true one and
if I were to do that same sort of testing on
kind I would have had to fill my route hard
drive because Docker right I don't have a
separate volume I have imagined I could do
some magic with doctor and have it use a
different volume and blah blah blah and Feel
That by Eminem and tried you actually I
tried to use NFS is a different storage
storage classes and kind and then filled in
NFS mountain and have that report and I
probably will end up doing it again anyway
but but another easy way to do that easier
way is to just at which also fills another
need which is to set up a true kubernetes
environment is to setup a virtual machine in
this is you'll see a bunch of old hats with
kubernetes on YouTube that's what they do
they pop up 3 or 4:10 different you know
computers virtual machines with vagrant and
an ale then configure those to run for
vanities and no the practice of the
community skills and they'll try their
different appointments and stuff then I'll
tear the whole thing down with you know one
vagrant come in and so that is what I seek
to do so that when I blow up the disk on a
virtual machine it doesn't touch the host of
operating system at all
so in my case coronavirus will run on top of
a VM yeah it's actually it's not as fast but
for the sake of testing and development of
being able to bring up a number and it's a
bit a bit of infrastructure and then bring
up vm's and then do that and then covering
it he's an install cameras on those virtual
machines if you think about it that's
exactly what's happening a Google and Amazon
and as they are running kubernetes in
Virtual machines every single one of them I
think I think some there's some of that are
starting to offer on metal but mostly they
are doing that already so they're already
running it on a virtual machine in that
gives you the flexibility to developer to
like messy or configuration and stuff and so
that's that's why I'm doing this I want to
be able to break things and not have it
break the host operating system and darker
is not good enough for that doctor might let
you mess with your files and just as
ephemeral
throw it away and make a new one which is
great for learning how to code and stuff but
when it comes to testing how am I going to
screw over the storage class by filling a
disc and really messing with it and that's
not the kind of thing that you can test with
containers because you need devices for that
and in order to have devices you have to
have a machine and in order to have a
machine without a physical machine you need
to be M so he thinks it's all foggy so
that's that's that's what's going on I know
I feel like you know burned myself out today
so I'm going to get no hard feelings if
anybody's watching you know somebody gave me
it works on my machine today and I got a
little bent out of shape by then cuz I was
frustrated no hard feelings to anybody will
be all back where we were again will be good
friends tomorrow but I appreciate it and
really when I push the edge the way I have
been I mean I've been literally sitting here
for the most part since noon
you know I I tend to to burn out quickly
when I'm trying to do too many things at
once but but I want to say that I feel like
today was a Monumental success I can't
believe it ended with me going back to
vagrant then that just blows my mind and I
can't I'm going to focus on the good things
I can't overstate my appreciation for chunky
who helped us fix liver knowing that there
were problems and being able to specifically
identify those problems would she have now
codified into something that could be
followed in fixed for anybody on a bun to
that is not something you're going to be
able to avoid if you want to run vagrant on
want to you're not going to able to get away
from that so yeah. Darker does have
limitations doctor is just at the end of the
day everything in dr. shares the same
underlying operating system and machine
Docker everything in Docker it might look
like a separate machine but it's not it's
sharing the same Colonel as sharing the same
memory Works in my machine if you say it
works on my machine you need to back it up
right
and you need to tell me what your machine is
and whether it's a bunch of my stuff like
that I just I don't I don't I've never dealt
with that I've never dealt well with the
with the works for me you're just a dumb ass
and you've obviously Fox something up that
that kind of attitude I have no Toleration
for that attitude at all and nit you run
into that attitude all the time MacGyver
actually that's where he's gone to because
he's given the same shit as well and I timed
him out
well and I can't imagine never came back if
you going to treat me like that or you like
that and they don't want to come back I'm
sorry I I don't want to do well on the drama
but I really don't give a shit people that
act like that and I TR toxic plague and I
just don't want him anywhere near me I am
toxic Enough by myself I can plenty toxic
you know and I think you should strive to
understand and and and you don't people do
do that and then they still think I do I
can't I don't know what I want to say it
works on the machine and if that's the truth
and you know at least back it up and he did
so temperature in your contacts cause 90% of
a drama yeah it's true it's true and I don't
want to make this an attack on a new one
person this is this is about it's more about
a personality type and if you're in it for
any amount of time you know these people
you've worked with these people people think
I am this guy and it too many and many times
I am that guy
you know and it's it's just doesn't help
that so curious if you increase the replica
set is there still is as soon as you say
machine if you're in Docker absolutely yeah
if using doctors your driver in Kinder
minikube both of which you sucker is it the
fault wherever that finds it yes the answer
is yes
if used MINI coop if use MINI Coupe with a
virtual machine or a liver driver it
actually makes a separate machine
and some people would argue that that's
maybe the way to do this if I can't let me
think about that for a second if I were to
use a mini cube with and I were to change
the driver in mini Cube it would actually
spin up actual machines that I could then
break and I wouldn't have to do the cut the
cube ATM stuff I kind of want to do the
Canadian stuff because I need to learn it as
well but but you don't make you the
difference between Cuban kind is it mini
Cube lets you use avert an actual virtual
machine
and kind kind does not know the virtual
machine that gives you is highly customized
to run to ronettis and it and you know you
can get over there and do your thing but I
don't know is if you do with vagrant then
you're actually install and committed
yourself to letting me keep sage in that
case has it's like it stalls. It is for you
and me keep does let you drive it right so
it can do that
so now sorry me too
make you
oh my gosh who am I copy. I hope I don't
have covid-19
you know I might have it God damn it this
feels like it
am I cry this is not an allergy this is
something different my son has covid is next
door
yeah I was confirmed he's only supposed to
be contagious for three more days
I know it doesn't equal, but I'm still
terrified omnicron doesn't get your sense of
taste is bad
I know
I am sure I don't have it I I I get allergic
to things to drink some hot tea I know
I'm sure something
yeah I'll be fine so
mini can help started leaving at 4 doctor in
vpod man out on this profile
teleservices Mount shuttle I do like this
might be the way to go actually
and I feel like crap I know I know I know
I've heard that story more than once
actually free people suck with that
let me just say
get some vitamin D think yeah yes yes vanity
and sink always works actually have that
stuff somewhere
I'm really glad that I we talk through this
just now because I think the fastest way to
test what I want is to use mini cube with
is to is to use mini cube with a Levert
driver
and I'm kind of curious right now
I'm kind of getting ahead of myself I'm not
going to sleep unless I look at
thank you that's not the kind of things you
do kind by the way image
OS and you can just not exist
Lincoln Logs
I don't remember right my kind of Mini
Cooper has a mixing up
interesting I want to do something here mini
Cube
I can do that. So nodes
I don't know it's too late snowed I think of
ways to catch a dance coffee
Lane service status
American not found right mini Cube let's
tell me about some
yeah okay so we can actually we could do one
I'll give you like the number of notes
everything how is it it's like
I'm trying to find it the most survivors is
a KVM
got if we could use it we may live right
driver window work before but I just
installed it so I think I can do it now
Advocate doctor finds them in order by the
way there's a box parallel to M & S H
remote SSH was that even mean that's Mac
well
Lenox Dr KVM KVM
god dammit give him being based preferred
entertain her legs container pod-man nunber
metal
what when do they have none
give him two mini Q
create cluster create SP
Heller
driver KVM to
a cube create
start KVM driver
Chris gave him TV unless it's not going to
work now because Kate many confusing it must
I turn it off
holy shit look at this it's using a Mini
Cooper I so it's actually doing like a
vagrant and creating a new image
and it's doing to I think it's 32 or the
richest thing one
is there any control plane node flooring
closer how's it going alley
Ali can't get on
hey Cat
more Cube system pod Courtney and S only
shit
holyshit
mksh Roselle
SP Color Oops
any cube is how fast that was holyshit
holyshit
wait I come isn't home darker I don't
supposed to be darker
I can't get no MK list MK
profile running Docker on time VM driver KVM
how is it doing a doctor run time though
it doesn't make any sense
what are the valid neq run times
in time antenna run time to PCS
doctor o m m m m n a c container engine I
feel stupid
the Emmys I just ran into him yeah as it
says
this is a VM this is 100% of e m
yeah it's a totally understand its own
network and everything
yeah watch said I had to do this I mean d a
p l c
I got
I mean that that might be in that might be a
pretty I think I might be in trouble here
are you see this it has see how much she a
little say a little Ramen has
now there's all on my computer that I'm
streaming from so
sh Moore
how many gig is a 14-9 see how things are
going for now you know why because the root
file system watch
agonize over the amounts you know what the
other or do they mail stuff from mini Cube
these are these are from this is so fucking
awesome this is a big me to get fat again it
look kind a Mini Cooper Fantastic Four
different reasons but this is really great
this fixes the problem I was having I don't
know why I didn't think about this before I
needed a miniature you can use a driver I
can blow up a Mini Coop node and not have it
touched my computer because he uses me a
driver you should be really careful because
the default for mini cube is to use Docker
if it finds on your system
how to start a clean environment absolutely
and that's what this is about the sun trying
to tell you this actually does everything
that I needed it sets it up it's got a
Docker container over here it's like an
amazing I mean this is really amazing
I just I don't know how this this is yet
another way to solve the problem
She-Ra somebody dropped out oh yeah starting
you know they're building yourself a cluster
or practicing test and get some certificates
or something and has lots of ways to get you
work right
this this is phenomenal to me
oh my God is running at CD and everything
this is so fucking awesome
I'm so glad we learn about Big Orange but
the difference is that
if I do it with vagrant then I have to set
up an ansible thing to set up the
communities environment when it Vinnie Cube
does all of that automatically for you
well I I actually I'm going to write about
this
any Cube with
the VM with a KVM to driver
when's a
for the win I have had a second to put kind
for fast
mini Cube Plus
KVM to driver for real
people like me asking a question
should I use KVM I mean should you use
unique you or kind to learn kubernetes are
people
yes both are amazing and essential
kind is the lightest-weight and the fastest
to set up
but mini Cube with a
true virtual machine driver like KVM
is the most real
real setup
I discovered this
I'll try and you to blow up a storage class
to see what would break and how I would know
so that I could write software to prevent it
such a task is very precarious with kind
since there is
nothing protecting your
hard drive that is being used as the default
storage class
but with a VM how many Q
There is no danger even if I he'll the disc
this is perfect for really testing
testing scenarios you hope you never
have to see in the real world it's like
being able to
to do controlled Burns
As A Firefighter and get good dealing with
them
mini Cube is ideal for this
it's worth mentioning
that if and if you
I want to get hands
on experience installing an Enterprise
scale simulation of kubernetes
on machines easy
is in Cuba ATM that vagrant
with the liverworts then avert
driver allows or that
it does
it sets up all the
emulated virtual machines your computer your
workstation can support
about 1 / 1 GHz
of CPU what's the estimate
and then you are free to do the rest
so yeah
cloud cnco
her native
I don't know what else to say. He's testing
operations yep
supposed to last
there you go that's my summary on that and
and on that note
I'm going to go ahead and I'm going to raid
at tennis who just came online and when
please say hi to hit I am going to go off
and play games we'll bit later tonight and I
don't know how long I'll be probably 5 10 15
minutes or something so again thank you
everybody I can't tell you how much fun this
has been at little thing at the end thereof
my summer is really been useful and going to
save me a lot of time tomorrow like a
tremendous amount of time I can have to set
a date or anything on the weekend when we
have time otherwise I'll see you guys later
let me see where's my Raider Channel thing
yeah nice
are you raid in one second by everybody